bald kommen die briefe der versorger
denn zum ersten oktober wird sie fällig
die sogenannte gas umlage noch einmal
mehrere hundert euro obendrauf auf die
ohnehin ihren preise auch die strom- und
heizölpreise klettern und der tank
rabatt fällt zum monatsende weg eine
ziemliche zumutung und für manche das
finanzielle aus der ärger der bürger
wächst und die regierung wird offenbar
nervös wenigstens die mehrwertsteuer auf
gas will sie jetzt senken wer versteht
dieses hin und her noch und wird energie
nicht dennoch bald unbezahlbar
wir müssen reden mit diesen gästen
omid nouripour vorsitzende von bündnis
90 die grünen
der fraktionsvize der union jens spahn
janine wissler vorsitzende der linken
der unternehmer arndt kirchhoff
klaus müller chef der bundesnetzagentur
und der moderator eckart von
hirschhausen sie sind zu gast bei
maybrit illner
und sie alle sind sehr herzlich begrüßt
in dieser sendung gaskunden in
deutschland liebe zuschauer fahren
momentan ganz schön achterbahn
die bundesregierung hat deshalb heute
entschieden die mehrwertsteuer auf
gasverbrauch zeitlich befristet auf 7
prozent abzusenken im sturm
explodierender energiepreise besinnt
sich der kanzler auf ein altes prinzip
linke tasche rechte tasche
zwar muss ein vier personen haushalt für
die umlage 518 euro mehr bezahlen wird
jetzt aber um gut 400 euro entlastet
durch die mehrwertsteuersenkung
mit nouripour ist bei uns einer der zwei
chefs von den grünen warum überhaupt ja
nur noch diese umlage wenn sie im grunde
fast den betrag an die menschen wieder
zurückgeben was sollte weil es darum
geht die einkäufer zu retten die
einkäufer die gas kaufen und auf den
markt bringen sind systemrelevant und
wenn die pleite gehen dann kollabiert
die versorgung und das können wir uns
nicht leisten und deshalb ist diese
umlage die niemand so wollte aber die
abhängigkeit der fossile die wir haben
von russland ist gewaltig dass die
russische seite damit spiele spielt und
versucht uns damit zu spalten ist
sichtbar und dementsprechend müssen wir
schauen dass wir die systemrelevanten
betriebe für die gasversorgung reden sie
retten mit der umlage und jetzt
entlasten sie parallel aber die richtig
in einer gleichen größenordnung und das
ist erst der anfang die
mehrwertsteuersenkung ist ein beitrag es
muss noch mehr kommen und wir werden uns
in den nächsten tagen und wochen darüber
beugen um ein drittes paket der
entlastung 2 haben wir schon beschlossen
auch auf den weg zu bringen denn es ist
offensichtlich dass die belastung gerade
für kleinere geldbeutel gewaltig ist und
wir werden als staatlich die gesamte
inflation die vorher schon da war
auffangen können aber wir werden sehr
viel mehr tun müssen damit die leute
gerade diesem winter gut durchkommen
weil man natürlich auch genug
sparanreize hätte wenn man allein auf
den preis für energie schaut da ist eine
vierköpfige familie hat marcel fritsche
noch mal ausgerechnet mit 3600 euro
dabei
die frage die sich viele menschen
stellen ist warum sie diese umlage
eigentlich nur auf die gas kunden
konzentrieren die die einsparungen sind
ja sie nicht endlos man kann ja nicht
einfach endlos gas sparen und wenn das
geld einfach nicht mehr da ist sagt na
gut dann wurde ich kein geld da sei es
nicht für alle also welcher bürger kann
was dafür dass er ein gasversorger hat
welcher bürger kann was dafür dass seine
fernwärme vielleicht aus gas krause sie
meint warum es jetzt quasi nicht
steuerlich finanziert wird sie an
sondern die anlage das ist eine gute
frage die sehr viel damit zusammenhängt
dass die staatsfinanzen so sind wie wir
sind wir sind beispielsweise der meinung
dass diese vielen entlastungen die wir
auf den weg bringen müssen auch uns auf
die frage stoßen was denn eigentlich mit
der schuldenbremse sein soll der die
möglichkeiten des staates geld
ausgegeben deckelt und gerade auf
christian schwere das ist nicht nur
christian lindner sind auch andere
dieser meinung sind das völlig egal wie
die lage ist die schulden geben so
bleiben muss wir werden ende des jahres
spätestens miteinander zusammen sitzen
müssen und überlegen müssen wie denn
eigentlich die staatlichen finanzen und
die ausgaben die dringend gebraucht
werden weil wir werden ja nicht nur
entlasten müssen wir werden ja auch
gleichzeitig die finanziellen risiken
umbau der industriegesellschaft
vorantreiben müssen wegen klimaschutz
wegen digitalisierung und vielem anderen
mehr das kostet alles geld und
dementsprechend ist die frage wie das
gehen soll ist es schon ich habe immer
noch nicht verstanden warum das jetzt
nur die gaskunden tragen warum sie nicht
sagen alle menschen sollen und können
einen beitrag dafür leisten dass
gasanbieter gasimporteure wie juniper
zum beispiel nicht sterben sollen wir
wollen ja die die systemrelevanten
juniper allen voran aber nicht nur
juniper retten und da geht es darum dass
wir jetzt eine gasanlage machen das was
sie beschreiben ist ja eher sowas wie
eine steuererhöhung und dass das hilft
ja das ist ja hilft ja auch nicht es ist
ja dann eine pauschale belastung von
menschen und deshalb ist es jetzt
notwendig dazu entlasten wo die leute
auch meisten abkriegen und zwar in
erster linie nicht durch die umlage so
einer deflation selbst aber die umlage
ist natürlich eine zusätzliche belastung
wir begrüßen jeden sparen den
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
der union herr sparen diese
mehrwertsteuersenkung die der
bundeskanzler heute ad hoc angekündigt
hat
vielleicht einen teil der umlage wieder
aus wenn sie eins zu eins weitergegeben
wird muss man dazu sagen sind sie damit
zufrieden nun
zuerst einmal muss man sagen frau immer
wir haben vieles von dem was die
bundesregierung in dieser krise die ja
plötzlich durch den krieg putins auf die
ukraine über uns gekommen ist auch bei
der energieversorgung vieles mitgetragen
und grundsätzlich ist es auch richtig
juniper andere gashändler zu stützen nur
was die letzten ein zwei wochen passiert
ist das ist ziemliches durcheinander aus
dieser gas umlage ist eine chaos umlage
geworden da werden nicht nur kosten
umgelegt sondern die regierung liegt
sozusagen ihr politisches internes chaos
auf die bürgerinnen und bürger um ich
war ja gerade im münsterland auch im
gespräch mit stadtwerken die wissen gar
nicht wie sie jetzt die verbraucher
informieren zum ersten zehn sie müssen
alle anschreiben sind viele fragen
ungeklärt und jetzt haben sich gerade
irgendwie alle damit auseinandergesetzt
dann kommt der kanzler rein in die
kartoffeln raus aus den kartoffeln sagt
man hier bei uns in westfalen macht auf
einmal die drehungen anders rum und sagt
über die mehrwertsteuer entlasten wir
praktisch die gleiche gruppe von
menschen um den gleichen betrag und dann
mit verlaub hätte man es auch gleich aus
dem bundeshaushalt finanzieren können
also wir bauen eine wahnsinns bürokratie
auf um die umlage umzusetzen entlasten
mit einer ähnlichen bürokratie dieselbe
gruppe dann hätte man diese rettung auch
gleich aus dem bundeshaushalt
finanzieren können und deswegen habe ich
einfach den konkreten vorschlag weil das
ist jetzt für die opposition eine schöne
zeit wir können viel kritisieren aber
wir müssen ja nach vorne in dieser krise
wenn die handwerklichen fehler dieser
umlage
behoben werden in einem gesetz wenn in
einem zweiten teil dieses gesetzes
kleinere mittlere einkommen wir müssen
doch gezielt entlasten und nicht über
eine mehrwertsteuer alle kleinere
mittlere einkommen gezielt entlastet
werden und wenn wir die knappheit etwa
beim strom blick auf kernenergie
beseitigen wenn es dann konkreten
vorschlag gelbe nächster woche
sondersitzungen bundestag beenden wir
dieses durcheinander machen wir ein
gesetzesbeschluss da ist schon wieder
gereicht der hand ich würde einmal noch
mal zu herrn in der hypo zurückfragen
selbst grüne also der
baden-württembergische finanzminister
dann ja bayers kritisiert dass diese
entscheidung heute des bundeskanzlers in
die völlig falsche ökonomische richtung
geht dieses knappe gut sollte nicht
pauschal für alle günstiger gemacht
werden die tiere aus einem dreht sondern
man sollte gezielt bedürftige entlasten
das ist interessanterweise an einer
stelle geht nahezu deckungsgleich mit
dem was herr spahn sagt also sie machen
etwas was die menschen nicht nur
verwirrt und wahnsinnig bürokratisches
und aufwendig ist sondern sie versagen
auch eben der zielrichtung weil sie
erreichen eben nicht dass ein teures
rares gut das schont wird und gespart
wird ich kann einen irren nicht so
richtig folgen zumal was du mein freund
dann ja da jetzt getwittert hat
deckungsgleich ist mit dem was sie
entspannen heute sagt im märz waren auch
für eine absenkung der mehrwertsteuer in
den bereich deshalb also ich würd ich
mir gar nicht verdenken wir fliegen alle
aufsicht und deshalb geht es natürlich
darum dass wir jeden tag von neuem
schauen was gebraucht wird was nicht
gebraucht wird ich kann dem nicht folgen
weil auf der einen seite es richtig ist
dass wir natürlich auch immer wieder
schauen müssen dass wir
klimaeffekte einbauen denn alles was wir
tun es ist dringend notwendig und das
werden wir auch tun auf der anderen
seite reden wir jetzt aber eine sehr
befristete maßnahme die hoffentlich dann
auch weg ist und damit man nicht die
umlage und wenn die umlage weg ist wird
auch die andere reduzierung der
mehrwertsteuer die politischen nouripour
ist ganz einfach haben wir diese umlage
jetzt nur weil christian lindner
eigentlich die stützung der gasversorger
nicht aus dem haushalt bezahlen und nein
weil wir die machen wir diesen ganzen
aufwand für ganz viele menschen weil die
ampeln sich nicht verständigen konnte
juniper aus dem haushalt zu retten weil
es nicht nur darum geht dass wir jetzt
so machen wie wir es bei lufthansa
gemacht haben wie wir es gemacht haben
in der in der pandemie oder als die
entspannung nicht zusammen im
haushaltsausschuss saßen 2008 folgende
um die rettungsschirme zu spannen nach
hin der in der finanzkrise oder für
griechenland sondern die reden hier über
ein laufendes geschäft bei juniper und
nun bei anderen und geht es darum dass
da sehr klar und deutlich formuliert
worden ist wie viel gas ist und
dementsprechend das jetzt umgesetzt wird
und umgelegt wird und natürlich wollte
die sollte die mehrwertsteuer nicht drin
sein
es ist aber europarechtlich haben wir
jetzt von der kommission wieder gehört
bekommen nicht anders möglich und selbst
dementsprechend gebe etwas einen anderen
weg der mag jetzt wirken wie in der
krücke entscheidend ist was hinten raus
kommt und das ist eine entlastung
das müsste man auch noch diskutieren wir
begrüßen zwischendurch einfach mal
fröhlich janine wissler eine der zwei
vorsitzenden der linken frau wissler
jetzt ist wenn man sich diese umlage
anschaut garantiert dass die großen
gasimporteure
90 prozent ihrer zusätzlichen kosten das
ist ein bisschen kompliziert ersetzt
bekommen eben weil dieses geschäft
vollständig weggebrochen ist
würde ihnen denn etwas anderes einfallen
wie man gasversorger in diesem land
schützt die bisher allein von russischem
gas abhängig waren fällt ihnen eine
andere lösung ein oder sagen sie nicht
auch diese versorger brauchen jetzt eine
unterstützung und eine staatliche
rettung brauchen sie aber man kann das
natürlich anders finanzieren und das
problem ist doch dass die gasanlage
jetzt wieder bedeutet dass die kosten
auf die verbraucher in verbraucher
abgewälzt werden und die
mehrwertsteuersenkung wird das auch eben
nicht vollausgleich wir dürfen ja nicht
vergessen wir haben die steigenden
preise bei den energiepreisen die sich
teilweise verdreifacht haben die
steigenden lebensmittelpreise steigende
mieten jetzt läuft das neun euro ticket
noch aus und es gibt keine
anschlussregelung das heißt die
fahrpreise werden auch noch deutlich
erhöht und das überfordert zunehmend
menschen finanziell und wir dürfen ja
nicht vergessen fast 14 millionen
menschen leben in diesem land in armut
an der armutsgrenze und deswegen ist es
einfach sozial unausgewogen was die
ampel dort macht also wir brauchen keine
gas umlage was jetzt wieder die
verbrauchern verbraucher belastet
sondern es wäre notwendig dass eben aus
dem steueraufkommen zu machen und um das
zu erhöhen fordern wir schon lange eine
über gewinn steuer da gibt es ja auch
durchaus sympathien mal den grünen und
der spd aber die fdp als schutzpatrone
der konzerne verhindert die und das ist
genau das problem wir kommen in dieser
krise nicht zu einer solidarischen
verteilung der kosten weil die über
gewinn steuert jetzt spanien zum
beispiel gerade einführt um damit den
kostenlosen öpnv zu finanzieren ja weil
es gibt einfach auch unternehmen die
hohe gewinne machen indem er diese zeit
und die st einen besonderen verdienst
sondern einfach nur glück meter sind
oder krisengewinnler wollte man
abschöpfen und sehr viel geld bringt
machen wir auch gleich noch mal die
runde und freuen uns aber dass an
kirchhoff heute bei uns ist er es
unternehmer präsident der vereinigung
der unternehmerverbände in nordrhein
westfalen sie sind auch noch bdi vize
und
automobilzulieferer jetzt sind
unternehmen wie ihres natürlich auch
gaskunden
sie brauchen gas und sie brauchen auch
richtig viel gas haben sie in diesem auf
und ab der letzten wochen irgendwie
schon den durchblick was da
kostentechnisch auf sie zukommt also es
gibt diese umlage dann ist jetzt die
mehrwertsteuer gesenkt es kommen noch
zwei weitere umlagen hinzu was der
bürger heute erfahren hat haben sie noch
den überblick und schon mal kurz
gerechnet natürlich gleich wenn wir
immer nur wir rechnen jeden tag aufs
neue weil wir jetzt seit gut zweieinhalb
jahren gewohnt sind sie lebt darin neue
situation vorzufinden die wir nun alle
miterlebt haben mich mit einer pandemie
wir haben krieg wir haben lieferketten
probleme materialengpässe vor ihnen
liegende schiffe und also das ist schon
eine sehr anstrengende zeit nicht mehr
für die unternehmen sondern für alle
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
unternehmen dann sehen wir mal dankbar
dass natürlich unsere politisch
verantwortlichen handeln und wir sind
gerne bereit so wie heute auch das wird
natürlich diskutieren was der beste weg
die presse mit leiden
gehört ja komm ich bin sehr dafür dass
man heute angefangen hat schritte zu
machen um den bürger zu entlasten denn
da wissen wir das kleine portemonnaie
ist extrem belastet durch inflation und
wir merken auch schon das große teile
des konsums und andere zurückgehen wir
müssen zusehen dass wir einigermaßen
unsere konjunktur auch am laufen halten
die muss am ende und die leistung der
wirtschaft muss am ende und die leistung
der frauen und männer in der wirtschaft
muss am ende die sache bezahlen also
müssen wir immer darauf achten dass der
laden weiter läuft jetzt ist es gut ich
hab gerade wie die bürger gesprochen
aber die unternehmen haben wir nur
kostensteigerungen an die hat noch
keiner gedacht die mehrwertsteuer wird
nicht bei unternehmen weil das ist als
umsatzsteuer ein durchlaufender posten
und müssen dringend an sogar von dieter
rencken hatte aber gar nichts und ich
habe ich mir schon mal angesprochen mit
dem 2,4 cent wie es nicht getan da
kommen noch weitere umlagen braucht also
müssen 20 prozent drauf rechnen dann
haben wir nämlich die kompletten kosten
die bei den unternehmen entstehen diesen
gewaltig die sind so gewaltig dass wenn
wir nichts tun würden viele unternehmen
aufgeben müssen könnte beispiele dazu
nennen und das was ich gerade in
nordrhein westfalen fragen von wie
vielen unternehmen wissen sie heute
schon dass sie kurz vor der pleite
stehen in anbetracht karriere die zahl
kann ich mich wenden ich kenne jetzt nur
einzelfälle angefangen von meinem
unternehmen wir sind nicht so ein großer
gasverbraucher aber wir sind angewiesen
auf zulieferer aus unserer kittel da
sind metalle dass sich emi produkte das
ist glas ein beispiel aus dem glas
bereichen mittelständischen unternehmen
250 mitarbeiter und 320 millionen
kilowattstunden gas kostensteigerungen
7,7 millionen euro
und das würde heute 30.000 euro pro
arbeitsplatz wenn man das ausgerechnet
so wenn wir jetzt zu hause als sie als
verbraucher eine glasscheibe kaufen
wollen dann müssen sie entweder das auch
bezahlen oder das unternehmen ein
riesenproblem der schlimmste fall ist
wenn das unternehmen kein gas mehr
bekommt dann friert ihn die anlage des
unternehmers zur politik das zu
produzieren komplett ein wie es für
immer verloren 260 arbeitsplätze
ebenfalls verlor das heißt das
beschreibt eigentlich welche
schwierigkeiten lage sind wir müssen
sehen dass wir möglichst allen so viel
gas gegeben dass wir den laden irgendwie
am laufen halten zu hause dass wir nicht
frieren hier unternehmen das die
produktion auf erhalten bleibt und da
müssen wir natürlich situativ jeden tag
die dinge angucken und müssen sehen aber
das erste was wir machen müssen ist
lösen weg finden wie wir auch die
wirtschaft entlasten über die nicht
einlassen dann ist das nicht nur in
unserem portemonnaie des verbrauchers
und solche zusätzlich noch nicht im
heutigen tag sodass wie soll ich dann
auch für verwerfungen die wir alle nicht
wollen können denn das sind am ende
unserer arbeitsplätze wir machen die
runde
zusätzlich zu den punkt den janine
wissler aufgebracht hat und fragen nach
den sogenannten über gewinnen sie dürfen
noch eine sekunde überlegen das ist
interessant in richtung grüne zu fragen
weil auch die spd offensichtlich gar
nicht abgeneigt ist darüber nachzudenken
die linke hat es ausgerechnet 30 bis 70
milliarden könnte man mit einer über
gewinn steuer von den firmen kassieren
die eben krisen oder kriegsgewinnler
waren ohne jetzt einen besonderen
zusätzlichen
gewinnen oder ein großes
einsparpotenzial vorweisen zu können wir
verhindert dass warum sagt man nicht
konzerne große konzerne die jetzt
riesengewinne machen die sollen von
ihrem überproportionalen gewinnen etwas
abgeben ich teile das und das ist auch
ehrlich gesagt etwas was sehr viel mehr
gerechtigkeitsempfinden dieses landes zu
tun hat ich empfinde es auch eigentlich
als widerspruch zu dem was sie gerade
gesagt haben kirchhof weil die
glasindustrie ist jetzt gerade einfach
massiv unter druck und ich teile sehr
dass die gas brauchen und wie geht es
auch gerade in der chemie geht es ja
nicht darum dass man gas abdreht und am
nächsten tag wieder aufdreht über diese
unternehmen reden wir nicht wir reden
über diejenigen die einfach wie sie
geschrieben haben durch nichtstun
einfach dasitzen und geldscheine
erzählen weil weil weil beispielsweise
die energiepreise durch die knappheit
die russland gerade produziert einfach
so durch die decke gehen und das team
beitrag dazu leisten müsse es ist aus
unserer sicht eine große klarheit und
das ist etwas was wir den nächsten tagen
auch noch mal in der koalition
miteinander diskutieren werden mitten
auf einem ergebnislosen begeisterung
offensichtlich auch in der spd kevin
kühnert sagt nur momentan sei der
bundeskanzler dagegen auch das ist ein
großer streitpunkt in der koalition
wieder wegen der fdp würden sie jetzt
beschreiben das camping grüne das so
gesagt hat dann sehen sie das ist nicht
nur eine fdp geschichte ist wir haben
eine koalition in der wir teilweise
weltanschaulich von verschiedenen ecken
kommen und dementsprechend sind wir
zusammen dass es könnte sein dass wir
werden das den nächsten tagen
miteinander diskutieren und dann werden
sicher ein drittes paket machen müssen
aus unserer sicht muss dieses paket auch
eindeutig parallel laufen zur umlage die
umlage kommt sollte auch dass das
nächste entlastungspaket dann auf den
weg gebracht werden und es gibt einige
vorschläge auf dem tisch und die über
gewünschter ist sicher eine der
sinnvollsten maßnahmen zu finanzieren
ganz interessanter punkt herr kircher
macht schon so ein bisschen den mund
auch das ist ein zeichen dafür dass es
nicht ihr lieblingsmodell ist aber sagen
sie nicht auch wenn er wie eh und shell
beispielsweise von sich aus schon
abwinken und sagen wir möchten überhaupt
gar keine zuwendungen seitens des
staates haben gibt es und andere
unternehmen die energieintensiv sind
einen riesenbedarf haben gibt es nicht
auch sympathie bei ihren kollegen die
sagen das ist tatsächlich für unfair da
gibt es jetzt eine menge unternehmer die
einfach glück sogar richtig schlucken
also zunächst mal halte ich das für eine
populistische diskussion die im
augenblick mainzer haben es überhaupt
nichts in unserer zeit verloren hat wir
haben ganz andere probleme und die wir
uns kümmern müssen mich versprachen eben
darum was ist mit dem bürger diese hoch
belastet ich sprach vor dem unternehmen
das sind meistens mittelständischen
familienunternehmen das sind die meisten
bei uns in deutschland das sind nicht
die großkonzerne dass die entlastet
werden müssen müssen wir uns darum
kümmern müssen damit die nicht aussagen
weil die ausstellung ist doch ein ganz
formal zu den jetzt kommen wir zu den
großen unternehmen sagen sie mir doch
was ist ein übergewicht wird definiert
nämlich über gewinnen das klingt für
populistisch
na ja das glaube ich nicht dass nur das
kann weil sie über gewinnen gucken sie
meiner pharma-branche müssen sie große
gewinner haben damit sie überhaupt die
investitionen in innovative stemmen das
haben gerade erlebt wie viel das kostet
in der pandemie in eine elegante und
klebstoffe und dann schauen sie mal in
der normalen branche wie zb der metall
und elektroindustrie oder jeder an
nannte arbeitet die industrie wie da die
gewinne aussehen da haben sie große
unterschiede zweistellige prozentzahlen
an beiden stellen können sie sagen das
ist viel zu viel oder zu wenig also ich
möchte erstmal jemand sehen dem man sagt
also über gewinnen und den gibt es
überhaupt nicht so insofern das zweite
ist ich glaube nicht dass das verpasste
sie macht beißen das dritte ist wir sind
ohnehin ein land war schon die
allerhöchsten steuerbelastung hat so wie
wir jetzt also nicht wirklich
investitionen abwürgen wollen wir haben
jetzt schon probleme mit
ausrüstungsinvestitionen blech verrät
diskutieren ständig der staat muss mehr
investieren das bruder will muss
schneller werden aber was ist denn mit
der privatindustrie die investiert seit
jahren viel zu wenig wie motivieren sie
nicht die kosten sind zu hoch die
energiekosten sowie so und wenn wir
jetzt auch noch die steuern anheben ja
dann befürchte ich ein aus für
arbeitsplätze lässt wirklich kann nur
davor warnen ich hatte mir hoch
populistisch das ist ein über gewinnen
geben möchte ich gerne selbst sagt wir
haben ja in vielen ländern der
europäischen union die das bereits
umgesetzt haben ich habe jetzt gerade
spanien genannt aber auch italien und es
gibt ja auch vorschläge der
eu-kommission dazu also es ist doch
nicht populistischer natürlich kann man
doch sehen wie sich gewinne auch im
vergleich zu den vorjahren entwickelt
haben und ich bin ja völlig bayern wenn
sie sagen man muss die bürgerinnen und
bürger entlasten und ich bin auch der
meinung es braucht dann tritt das
entlastungspaket gerade für die
rentnerinnen und rentner für die
menschen mit kleinen und mittleren
einkommen für die menschen im hartz
iv-bezug aber die frage ist doch wer
soll das denn finanzieren und wenn wir
uns einig sind das ist entlastung
braucht dann muss es doch irgendwo
finanziert werden wir sehen doch unter
die lupe und wir sehen doch
arbeitende bürger stellen zu machen wenn
du aber das geht ja und jetzt geht ja um
sehr sehr hohe gewinne und nicht rum
unternehmen die von diesen hatten die
idee schon holen geht nicht um
unternehmen die jetzt von der insolvenz
bedroht sind aber die alternative sehen
wir doch jetzt gerade nämlich jetzt
wehrt die kosten werden auf die
verbrauchern verbraucher haupt gewählt
und zwar ausgerechnet die die
zufälligerweise eine gasheizung haben
worauf mieterinnen und mieter ja
überhaupt keinen einfluss haben nachdem
wir heute noch jahrelang erzählt wurde
sollen die ölheizung und später machte
er als
student notwendig dass wir hierbei eine
andere steuerpolitik auch über die über
gewinnen steuer hinaus reden und zum
anderen will ich noch mal deutlich
machen so sind teuer schwer und man
würde sehr viel mehr den verbrauchern
verbrauchern helfen wenn man über
gaspreis deckel sprechen würde auch die
gibt es in einigen ländern der
europäischen union wo strom und
gaspreise reguliert sondern es gab ja
auch in deutschland bis 2007 eine
staatliche strompreis aufsicht und strom
und gas sind nicht güter wie alles
andere sondern sie sind essentiell und
deswegen bin ich der meinung brauchen
wir kostengünstige grund kontingente für
menschen ja damit eben klar ist dass
niemand im winter in kalten in seiner
wohnung sitzen muss das niemanden
deswegen wäre das auch so wichtig die
idee mit dem moratorium zumindest was
die strom und gas sperren angeht
wo er auch die fdp offensichtlich nicht
überzeugt ist dass es da jetzt das
moratorium gibt das strom und gas
sperren verhindert werden damit niemand
im winter in seiner wohnung frieren muss
weil er seine gasheizung er seine
gasrechnung nicht bezahlen kann wir sind
noch mal herr 0 sammelt immer noch die
argumente wir sind noch mal in münster
bei herrn spahn ersparen in ihren
argumenten ist interessant dass sie
gerade für die kleinen und mittleren
einkommen plädieren gerade für die
kleinen und mittleren unternehmen
natürlich auch kämpfen
ist in ihren ohren plötzlich auch an
eine über gewinn abgabe oder steuer zu
denken wie immer man das definiert um
eben auf diese milliarden zukommen die
gasanbieter
gasimporteure jetzt zur stützung
brauchen um nicht zu stark
also zuerst einmal was die stützung der
gashändler angeht um das system das geht
ja nicht darum dass juniper nicht in die
insolvenz geht das ist nicht
entscheidend sondern entscheidend ist
dass wenn es in die insolvenz ginge das
gas versorgungssystem zusammenbrechen
würde und deswegen ist es eben richtig
zu stützen wie gesagt das könnte man
eigentlich besser wenn man das jetzt
schon alles so komisch macht erst eine
umlage dann die mehrwertsteuer für
dieselbe gruppe besser aus dem
bundeshaushalt finanzieren was ihr aber
viel wichtiger finde ist tatsächlich und
das ist im soziale marktwirtschaft
soziale härten abzufedern die preise
wirken zu lassen das ist marktwirtschaft
und diese hohen gaspreise setzen anreize
ja auch zum sparen bei den vielen
menschen jetzt schon auch in der
industrie und gleichzeitig mit den
preisen die wirken soziale härten
abfedern und das und das ist wichtige
schon gesagt worden nicht nur da ist es
wichtig bei kleinen einkommen sondern
auch bei den mittleren einkommen es gibt
hier viele nicht nur im münsterland hier
sondern in ganz deutschland die mit 2000
2200 euro 2500 euro netto ihre familie
ernähren und einfach nicht mehr können
bei diesen preisen
gas grundbedarf so würde ich es nennen
energie grundbedarf wo man sagt und
durchschnittlicher haushalt braucht
nennt meine größe die muss man
definieren 7 8000 kilowattstunden gas im
jahr und diesem grund bedarf gibt es zum
gleichen preis wie letztes jahr
spiel das kann ich mir gut vorstellen
das ist ein anreiz dann weil alles
darüber wird dann richtig viel kosten
eben nicht zuviel zu verbrauchen und
gleichzeitig entlastete es
überproportional kleinere mittlere
einkommen aber einen gedanken zu
übergewicht eingelangten zu über
gewinnsteuer wenn ich kurz davor ist
spannende ist ja und da hat ja herr
kirchhoff recht wie wollen sie über
gewinnen definieren und da bin ich
wieder bei der frage auch von markt und
marktwirtschaft wir haben ein bereich wo
das mit den preisen ja nicht so richtig
im markt funktioniert das ist nämlich
genau der strompreis der strompreis das
ist sehr komplex aber in einfachen
worten orientiert sich immer an dem
letzten teuersten stromproduzenten und
das ist im moment sind gaskraftwerke die
sogenannte merit order heißt das im
fachbegriff egal das führt dazu im
ergebnis wir haben sehr hohe strompreise
aber nicht in einem wirklichen markt und
dabei gewinnen nicht nur rwe und e.on
sondern übrigens auch erneuerbare
energien ich habe heute mit windenergie
erzeugung gesprochen die sagen wir
hätten nie gedacht dass wir jemals so
viel geld verdienen könnten mit einer
windenergieanlage
gaskraftwerke bestimmen wie viel geld
wir kriegen so und und dann mechanismus
zu finden wer klug ist der abgrenzbar
ist wie da diese hohen gewinne die
eigentlich nichts mit markt zu tun haben
sondern eher mit einem komischen
preissetzung system genutzt werden
könnten etwa eben um sozialen ausgleich
zu schaffen ich finde das ist zumindest
ein allein in werth und auch alle
gedanken wert aber es muss vor allem
nehmen auch zu einem ergebnis kommen und
da bin ich beim letzten punkt weil dem
was sie angesprochen haben der
diskussion gerade der finanzminister und
der wirtschaftsminister der
bundesrepublik deutschland der
industrienationen in der mitte europas
eines g7 staates mitten in einer der
größten wirtschaftskrisen streits seiten
entlassen inflation sind im täglichen
streit im täglichen streit
wirklich das gegenteil wissen sie ich
werde mal auf der seite derjenigen die
sich einfach wünschen dass diese
regierung nicht streitet sondern bei den
entlastungen entscheidet und eine
richtung vorgibt das ist doch das was im
moment führt fehlt führt führung fehlt
der kanzler sagt wer bei mir führung
bestellt der bekommt auch welche ich
sehe einfach keine wir brauchen
entscheidungen bei den entlastungen und
wir brauchen entscheidungen darüber wie
wir die mehrbelastung die es gibt
vernünftig umsetzen ich sage noch einmal
wenn es vernünftige vorschläge gibt
werden wir als cdu csu auch in der
opposition bereit sein damit
verantwortung zu übernehmen aber erst
über konkrete vorschläge auf die sich
die regierung einigt bevor wir zu klaus
müller nach wunsch alten herrn nochmal
bei der frage warum gehen sie
beispielsweise auch so einen vorschlag
der identisch bei linken und auch der
cdu csu diskutiert wird nicht 1 zu sagen
wir haben einen bestimmten einen
gasverbrauchs deckel den wir anziehen um
erstmal die sorge der bürger zu
minimieren oder am allerliebsten kaputt
zu machen
dass sie nicht mit gas versorgt werden
im gegenteil ich hab wirklich einen satz
sagen zu der über gewinnsteuern noch so
ja auch in recke weil man kann darüber
streiten was das richtige konzept ist
ungefähr so intoniert wie entspannen das
gemacht hat darauf kann man sich glaube
ich auch einigen aber ich warne davor
dass man so tut als wäre es eine
allgemeine unternehmensbesteuerung es
geht nicht darum dass wir alle belasten
sie haben völlig zurecht beschrieben die
gas intensiven unternehmen wie sehr sie
massiv unter druck sind das ist nicht
das thema das ist nicht das thema das
thema sind diejenigen die die energie
verknappung durch russland gerade
einfach einfach jetzt
nicht zwingen nutzen aber jetzt einfach
geld in die kasse gespült bekommen wie
noch nie und wenn wir jetzt über
erneuerbare reden wie sie entspannen
gemacht hat ja auch die wenn wir über
gewinnt dementsprechend so definierten
müssen wir auch über die rede ist
überhaupt keine frage aber nicht die die
not sind ist nicht das thema verzeihung
und jetzt nochmal zu der frage von von
preisen decke und zum thema
sperren ich finde absolut richtig das
ist auch ein vorschlag den die
verbraucherschutzministerin steffi lemke
gemacht hat das ist ein moratorium geben
darf dass es nicht sein kann dass gerade
in diesem kommenden winter die leute
jetzt gas sperren bekommen weil sie die
rechnungen nicht mehr bezahlen kann oder
strom sparen und im schlimmsten fall
beides ist ja auch die unternehmen sie
noch nicht zwingend gleich das kann sein
dass beides passiert ohne dass jemand
drauf geguckt hat das wäre verheerend
wir brauchen moratorium auch dass es im
paket dessen was in den nächsten tagen
miteinander in der koalition besprechen
werden und dann entscheiden werden beim
decke bin ich ein bisschen
zurückhaltender weil es sie haben vorhin
den tweet von daniel bahrs genannte da
bin ich in der stätte verpassen bei ihm
ich glaube dass man nicht zwingend so
tun sollte also wären wir beim gas wo
wir nicht in erster linie ein markt
problem haben sondern ein physikalisches
problem haben dass wir an der stelle so
tun sollten als wäre das ein floß da ist
einfach schlicht nicht der fall und es
würde nichts mehr fahren können regen
sagen sie das ist richtig wir sind allen
dieses budget zur verfügung stellen auch
denen die sich eigentlich leisten
könnten oder 14 auch das spricht dafür
dass man selbstverständlich schaue dass
man gezielt da wo es am meisten
gebraucht wird zwischen
grundbudget was dazu schon ein anreiz
gibt auch energie einzusparen weil wir
natürlich über klimaschutz
energieeinsparung reden und dass man
wirklich einen intensiven verbrauch
daneben auch ja gleich eben eben höher
das ist das und das ist dass ich würde
aber halt die armen haushalte besonders
entlasten weil die halt dann einfach
auch oft die möglichkeit nicht haben
ihre wohnung energetisch zu sanieren
noch mehr zu sparen und ich meinen die
leute die die ganze zeit jetzt und die
mentoren sagen ja auch viel sparen doch
seid ja überall wo sollen wir dann noch
sparen also von daher version
kostengünstiges grund kontingent was
eben einfach die grundversorgung sichern
würde durchaus auch einen anreiz zum 11
sie haben nicht endlos mittel zur
entlastung müssen gezielt dabei den
schwächsten tatsächlich beginnen so und
das sind aber die interessanten fragen
weil erst mal müssen jetzt alle anfangen
zu rechnen und dabei hilft uns
zuallererst und an dieser stelle einer
der sich wirklich auskennen muss der
präsident der bundesnetzagentur nämlich
klaus müller und er steht uns
freundlicherweise in und aus bonn
geschaltet zur verfügung herr müller die
preise gehen bis zur decke da kommt
jetzt eine umlage drauf dann wird diese
umlage wieder verbessert mit dieser
mehrwertsteuer-senkung die nun heute
bekannt wurde plus noch 2 weitere
umlagen haben sie das gefühl dass das
der bürger noch versteht
ich glaube dass der dass die bürgerinnen
und die bürger verstehen dass fossiles
gas und die abhängigkeit von russland
sehr sehr teuer zu stehen kommt und das
sind auch die drei anlagen über die wir
jetzt reden er das eine ist die rettung
der stadtwerke oder wie jens spahn und
ob nicht nur richtig gesagt haben die
rettung der energie importeure zweitens
es geht um eine gasspeicher umlage wir
müssen die deutschen speicher befüllen
die uns russland teilweise sehr sehr
leer übergeben hat im frühjahr und das
drittes die marktgebiets
verantwortlichen die bilanz kreis
verantwortlichen müssen für einen
ausgleich in den gas systemen sorgen
auch das ist durch die letzten wochen
und monate schwieriger geworden dass es
die bilanzierungs umlage alles sind
umlagen alles in preisbestandteile die
uns leider die aktuelle situation und
die ehemalige abhängigkeit von russland
eingebracht jetzt kann man heute am tag
von dieser mehrwertsteuersenkung lesen
und hören die der bundeskanzler
offensichtlich sehr schnell entschieden
hat nach dem da aus brüssel entsprechend
hinweise kamen
wann haben sie von der
mehrwertsteuersenkung erfahren herr
müller darf ich das mal fragen
rechtzeitig
rechtzeitig also heißt dann um 11 heute
ich bleibe bei der formulierung
rechtzeitig die behörden wie die
bundesnetzagentur und die
bundesregierung sind einem fortlaufenden
austausch und das ist das einzige worauf
es ankommen
135 eur 155 euro kommen mit diesen
beiden anderen auch umlagen da jetzt
noch dazu glauben sie dass das alles was
zum ersten zehn die bürger erreichen
soll dass das in den be und entlastungen
auch gesetzeskonform
überhaupt noch rechtzeitig den kunden
ermittelt und vermittelt werden kann
es gibt ja regelungen im
verbraucherrecht die eben eine
sechswöchige vorherige ankündigungsfrist
beinhalten neben der normalen umständen
ist dass die frist in der sie den
gasanbieter wechseln können das ist
momentan nicht wirklich real weil sie
kaum einen günstigen anbieter finden
aber ich bin fest davon überzeugt die
bundesregierung ist absolut in der lage
dass alles rechtskonform umzusetzen ja
es ist gerade alles sehr knapp das liegt
aber an der aktuellen lage dass man
juniper schnell retten musste dass die
eu-kommission sich so positioniert hat
die sich positioniert hat auch an sie
die frage die wir hier nicht vollständig
aufklären konnten ist erklärbar warum
man sich nur auf gas kunden konzentriert
also warum werden nur bürger jetzt mit
dieser umlage konfrontiert die gas
empfangen und nicht die die erdöl- oder
mit strom heizen
glaube darauf gibt es eine relativ gute
antwort weil auch der ölpreis enorm
gestiegen ist und ich glaube jemand der
mit öl heizt er sehr gut uns vor rechnen
kann wie stark sie oder er belastet ist
und ich glaube die würden es als sehr
ungerecht empfinden wenn sie jetzt auch
noch eine gasanlage zu sich hätten
obwohl sie mit der problematik
russischen gases und unsere abhängigkeit
nichts zu tun haben ein anderes beispiel
menschen haben sich für solarthermie
oder holzhackschnitzel entschieden ja
das heißt für erneuerbare heizsysteme
ich glaube auch die würden es nicht als
gerecht empfinden wenn sie jetzt mit
eine oben lage für russisches gas
bezahlen müssten gut bei der
finanzmarktkrise war es ja überhaupt gar
keine frage dass man das eben
einheitlich alle bürger tragen lässt bis
zu einem bestimmten punkt es ist einfach
wirklich schwer das nachzuvollziehen
78 entschuldigung 77,8 prozent voll wird
heute vermeldet sind die speicher
mittlerweile und trotzdem herr müller
warnen sie dass wir das nicht schaffen
könnten dass wir noch viel mehr sparen
müssten
diese maßnahmen auch des heutigen tages
animieren die weiter zum sparen
der preisdruck ist einer der härtesten
sparanreize die es bei uns in der
gesellschaft gibt wir sehen dass das in
der industrie jetzt schon seit einigen
monaten wird sehen hier strukturelle
einsparungen bei der industrie dort sind
die preise ja auch schon sehr sehr voll
durchgeschlagen der kirche war das ja
vorhin beschrieben bei den privaten
haushalten passiert das jetzt gerade
jeden tag rufen mich freunde bekannte
arbeitskollegen an die von erhöhten
gasrechnung abschlagszahlung berichten
und das ist furchtbar und bitter darüber
wurde gerade von allen diskutanten schon
berichtet aber es ist eben ein teil des
reizes den wir brauchen die gasspeicher
befüllen sich das ist sehr sehr wichtig
weil es ein puffer ist aber die erste
die wir in die gasspeicher reihen setzen
können das sind immer die leichtesten
aus physikalischen gründen danach wird
es einfach immer schwerer sie können das
etwas salopp mit einer fahrradreifen auf
pump aktion vergleichen ist ja es ist
ein kleiner empfang reicht das gar die
luft rein zu pumpen genau später wird es
aber immer schwerer das heißt die 85 die
95 prozent die wir erreichen wollen die
sind physikalisch anstrengender darum
mahne ich und es reicht auch nicht sich
auf die speicher zu verlassen die
alleine würden uns nicht durch einen
winter durch tragen wenn es besonders
kalt wird oder putin das gas komplett ab
drehen sollte und dann liest man jetzt
herr müller dass wir gas und strom aber
eben auch strom den wir noch aus gas
gewinnen sogar steigern also wir
steigern unsere verstromung aus gas
obwohl wir gas ja sparen müssen akut
jetzt um es an die franzosen weiter zu
geben die gerade viele akw abschalten
und offensichtlich unsere solidarität
brauchen wird uns dieses gas fehlen
das ist eine sehr gute frage die
beschäftigt die bundesnetzagentur die
bundesregierung die wissenschaftler
tagtäglich erstmal sie haben das
vollkommen richtig beschrieben wir
brauchen gas einmal für kraft wärme
kopplungsanlagen das sind auch
geschützte kunden weil sie wärme für
private haushalte krankenhäuser
pflegeheime produzieren wir brauchen
gaskraftwerke als regelenergie
spitzenausgleich darauf können wir nie
ganz verzichten und der größte block ist
tatsächlich der den sie beschrieben
haben unsere französischen nachbarn
haben ein ganz gravierendes problem mit
ihren atomkraftwerken und die zahlen
zurzeit einen gigantischen strompreis
die in frankreich so noch nicht erlebt
hat und das bedeutet trotz der extrem
hohen gaspreise lohnt es sich für
frankreich gas aus deutschland zu kaufen
und der spaß hat er folgende merit order
richtig beschrieben diese merit order
wird gerade angeheizt durch unsere
französischen nachbarn und es ist eine
ganz schwierige abwägung da wir stand
heute die gasspeicher weiter befüllen
können glaube ich ist das ok es ist
nicht schön es ist nicht gut aber ich
glaube es ist okay mit blick auf den
nächsten monate hoffe ich dass die
situation in frankreich besser wird und
dann greifen natürlich auch die gesetze
der bundesregierung und ich gehe davon
aus dann würde die gasverstromung
deutlich sinken wenn wladimir putin das
gas abdreht ist es dann auch möglich und
die diskussion ist für sie nicht neu ist
es dann auch möglich dass sie bei
privathaushalten doch einsparen und
rationieren aus fairness und
gerechtigkeit gründen das wünscht sich
beispielsweise die wirtschaft sehr auch
herr kirchhoff der heute unser gast ist
weil er sagt dass die industrie ohnehin
laut gesetzeslage kunde zweiter klasse
ist
das ist richtig beschrieben die
europäische rechtslage ist hier absolut
eindeutig und wir haben ja so
diskussionen darüber gehört kürzlich
haben viele menschen heizlüfter
eingekauft was so möglich unsere neue
probleme im stromsektor bescheren könnte
darum glaube ich ist wichtig
festzuhalten für die bundesnetzagentur
im fall einer gasanlage gilt der
besonderen schutzstatus der privaten
haushalte der krankenhäuser der schulen
der polizeistation etc aber ich glaube
es ist eine frage der solidarität und
meine dringende bitte und wie gesagt die
harten preise über die berater
diskutiert haben setzen ja auch die
anreize dass auch im privaten bereich
eingespart werden muss und jede
kilowattstunde an gas die wir dort
einsparen hilft uns eine reduzierung
oder im schlimmsten fall eine
abschaltung in der industrie zu
vermeiden und die bundesnetzagentur wird
eben nicht müde zu betonen wir wollen
diese gasmenge lage nicht wir müssen sie
vermeiden und dazu gehört solidarität
mit den arbeitsplätzen und den produkten
die wir dort herstellen und die wir
brauchen lebensmittel medikamente und
das heißt sie machen sich genau diese
sorgen weil das eine gesetzes eine
gesetzgebung aus friedenszeiten ist
hatte man nie damit gerechnet dass ein
solcher krieg kommen würde ich zitiere
sie glaube ich das ist richtig
das ist glaube ich unbestritten und auch
alle politiker die das damals mit
entschieden haben konnten sich die
heutige situation nicht vorstellen und
jetzt werde ich dafür sich auf diesen
winter vorzubereiten diesen winter gut
zu managen und diesen winter werden wir
nur durch einen dreiklang gut bestehen
nämlich indem wir zusätzliches gas
bekommen daran arbeitet die
bundesregierung da gibt es auch gute
signale über das bisherige maß hinaus
indem wir ein speichern das tun wir auch
und indem wir einsparen in unseren
szenarien müssen dass mindestens 20
prozent über alle sektoren hinweg sein
dann kommen wir ohne eine mangel lage
mit bisschen glück wenn der winter
normal bleibt durch die nächsten monate
das wäre mir wichtig und dann wird man
das sicherlich nochmal evaluieren können
im nächsten jahr weil dann der nächste
winter kommt und wir müssen mindestens
zwei winter bestehen damit wir dann
nachher unabhängig von russischem gas
also da bleibt es bei dem appell das
haben wir klar verstanden weil es
juristisch und nach gesetzeslage erstmal
nicht möglich ist auch gas also private
gaskunden mit gas rationierungen
zu konfrontieren herr müller vielen dank
dass sie uns heute mit ihrer expertise
zur verfügung gestellt gestanden haben
wir diskutieren in der runde hier weiter
herr kirchhoff ist es für sie akzeptabel
zu sagen wir sparen und rufen den
privaten bürger auf auch den vielleicht
sehr reichen privaten bürger da ist es
nicht möglich ihm eben auch zu
sanktionieren wenn er denkt dass er
weiter den pool heizen muss mit gas und
anderes mehr also wir haben deswegen
auch die gesetzeslage die ist noch klar
als gesetz aus dem letzten jahrhundert
bezeichnet er bereits gesagt da waren
uns kriege und sogar margen lagen noch
nicht bekannt er hat mich vorstellbar
für uns machen wir haben dann schon im
märz darauf hingewiesen dass wir gesagt
haben also lasst uns bitte einen weg
einschlagen und ich sehe es bisher auch
dass die politik genau das tut wo wir
auch beides rücksicht nehmen auf das
eine das natürlich die bürger nicht
frieren zu hause dann aber gleichzeitig
auch ihr arbeitsplatz nicht gefährdet
ist denn es nützt nichts wenn es zu
hause im warmen sitzung die arbeit ist
weg nicht und die beispiele kann man
dann vielfach diskutieren sowie gesagt
lasst uns versuchen das war auch beides
achten nun ist das nicht im einzelfall
so leicht zu regeln nicht mehr kannte
man halt mich regeln insofern muss man
dann noch das haben wir insbesondere im
wirtschaftsbund wird schon so
klimaminister er recht früh diskutiert
anfang märz schon gesagt also dann lasst
uns mit appellieren dass uns eine
gemeinsame kraftanstrengung für daraus
machen wir haben die krise den letzten
zehn jahren angefangen von der finanz
und immobilienkrise dann die pandemie
und jetzt auch die ersten kriegstage und
was dann so durcheinander kam haben wir
bisher eigentlich aus deutschland ich
glaube ich gut gemacht indem er
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt hatten
deswegen muss auch in diesem fall wieder
appellieren lasst uns das zusammen
machen ich glaube der bürger sieht
sofort ein wenn du dich mit zur arbeit
gehen kann weil der betrieb nicht läuft
dass man ihnen keinen gefallen damit tut
obwohl die reihenfolge so sagen würde
unstreitig ist dass die kritische
infrastruktur wagenhäuser polizei die
muss bevorzugt werden aber der rest muss
versuchen zu sparen was geht denn nur
dann werden wir auch diesmal und da bin
ich ziemlich zuversichtlich diese
schwierige lage über kommen vor wissler
sparen für den frieden und frieren
vielleicht im winter für den frieden
aber auch für die arbeitsplätze daher
mit dem frieren für den frieden reden ja
vor allem die leute die am ende nicht
frieren werden weil sie auch weiterhin
ihrer gasrechnungen bezahlen können ich
will nur einen punkt mehr sagen weil ich
finde wir müssen schon ein bisschen
tiefer gehenden die ursachen
beschreibung und ich finde man kann die
situation die wir jetzt haben nicht
erklären ohne auch eine verfehlte
energiepolitik der letzten zehn zwanzig
dreißig jahre weil das aus einer so hohe
abhängigkeit von fossilen energien gibt
von gas von kohle von atomkraft im
übrigen weil herr spanier immer
vorschlägt auch die atom die laufzeiten
für die atomkraftwerke zu verlängern für
frankreich zeit gerade ganz gut welche
probleme wir bekommen und ich finde wir
können diese gaskrise jetzt nicht lösen
indem wir andere krisen verschärfen dass
es am ende eine renaissance der kohle
kraft gibt ja ich habe gerade die
absurde situation dass man auf dem rhein
ist so niedrig wasser ist dass man jetzt
noch weniger kohle transportieren kann
ich finde das zeigt sehr sinnbildlich wo
das problem ist dass eben eine folge des
klimawandels dazu führt dass man weniger
kohle transportieren kann also ich will
nur sagen wir wären heute nicht in
dieser situation einer abhängigkeit von
fossilen energien und damit auch von
russland aber nicht nur russland wenn
man die energiewende voran gemeinschaft
dem handy geschlafen hätte sich aber
immer ergeben energie ausgebaut hätte
wenn man die wärmepumpen wenn man
solarthermie wenn man nicht überall
versucht hätte die energiewende
auszubrennen so und sich so wirklich
sehenden auges und das nicht so dass
dann niemand vorgewarnt hat in den
letzten jahren auch aus vor allem aus
klimaschutzgründen aber sich soeben in
die abhängigkeit gebracht hat das finde
ich es interessant wie sich in ihren
pfleger argumentationsgrundlage bleiben
wir noch mal dabei paul wißler dass ihre
partei jetzt aufgerufen hat zu
montagsdemonstrationen
sie möchten der regierung im wahrsten
sinne des wortes einen heißen herbst
bescheren und kündigen
montagsdemonstrationen an sind sie mit
dabei marschieren sie mit wir haben zu
protesten aufgerufen und das heißt ich
absolut für notwendig und richtig enrico
hat ja eben ein paar sachen gesagt wo
jetzt in den nächsten tagen die
regierung auch noch einmal verhandeln
wird thema verbot von stromsperren thema
über gewinn steuer und ich finde wir
brauchen hier einen gesellschaftlichen
druck und deswegen ist für mich jetzt
weniger entscheiden an welchem tag die
demonstrationen stattfinden wichtig ist
dass es dabei um sozialen ausgleich geht
und hin verteilung weil viele menschen
wirklich das wasser bis zum hals steht
und ich finde für uns als linke ist doch
eine ureigene aufgabe soziale proteste
zu organisieren
linke alternativen aufzuzeigen damit
dass eben druck gibt viele über gewinn
steuer führenden gaspreis deckel und
dafür dass es endlich ein drittes
entlastungspaket gibt nämlich dass die
menschen zum beispiel im hartz-iv-bezug
eben auch jetzt entlastet werden die
menschen mit kleinen und mittleren
einkommen weil das sind eben nicht nur
die energie ag sind die mieten und das
sind die lebens mit der kirche aber
gleich wieder die augenbrauen hoch die
hat hier empfänger kommen sorry for
whistler natürlich eigentlich jetzt mit
all den entlastungen noch ganz gut
zurecht weil sie im übrigen eben auch
beim heizen gar nicht so schlecht
gestellt werden das zahlt ja der staat
die rentner sind beim letzten mal
fatalerweise vergessen worden es ist
wirklich schwer das umzusetzen nämlich
die menschen zielgenau zu entlasten die
man entlasten will frage an einen
manager wie würden sie denn genau die in
der mitte die für eine vollständige
subventionierung zu viel verdienen und
die aber auch nicht reich sind in der
situation stützen wird ich glaube uns
allen ist klar dass für alle gürtel
enger schnallen müssen und das war auch
ein stückweit verzichten müssen ich
glaube dazu bereit und deswegen ist ja
die aufgabe wie auch schon beschrieben
von den neubau von herrn sparen das war
jetzt sehen dass wir die schwächsten
zunächst mal entlasten die pläne dafür
zu gucken das wird auch die
arbeitsplätze auf den mittelstand auch
die unternehmen achten und auch so
entlasten dass die überleben können weil
beides gehört zusammen ich glaube ich
habe das geschildert und ansonsten kann
ich nur und das war bisher immer gut an
die solidarität in unserer gesellschaft
appellieren das ist glaube ich das hat
geklappt ich warne davor hobbys muss ich
ehrlich sagen überlegen sich mal für wen
sie für werden sie demonstrieren gehen
wer hat denn das gas abgedreht das doch
eher routing wollen sie bitte auf die
straße gehen zu sagen was er butting
gemacht hat das ist super also das würde
ich überhaupt nicht verstehen modena war
mir sehr besorgt natürlich geht es darum
nein also da überlegen sie doch mal auf
so dass wir kennen die treibenden spalt
zwischen die gesellschaft das natürlich
mit solidarität zu tun und ich rede also
die soziale spaltung dieser gesellschaft
die haben nicht mehr verursacht und eine
falsche politik für zur million menschen
leben in armut sie sprechen davon wir
müssen alle den gürtel enger schnallen
wir reden hier von menschen die
regelmäßig in tränen ausbrechen wenn sie
den wocheneinkauf machen wir reden hier
von menschen die ihren kindern jedem
einkauf erklären müssen warum sie das
oder das nicht kaufen können weil kein
geld da ist wir reden von menschen
und ich will nur sagen die hartz iv
gesetze sind diesem jahr um drei euro
gestiegen das sind 0,7 prozent bei 8
prozent inflation also nicht zu starker
schmerzen jochen von mir alle müssen
gucken wann die ankündigung rechne ich
mir alle müssen den gürtel enger
schnallen es gibt viele menschen die
wissen überhaupt die abo kein knopfloch
mehr wo sie den gürtel noch enger
schnallen können sondern die verzichten
seit jahren auf alles und es geht
überhaupt nicht um die frage
jetzt einfach zu sagen wir demonstrieren
für putin das ist doch völliger unsinn
es geht um die frage wie wir als
gesellschaft wie gehen die die
interpretieren medien gesellschaft und
die situation um lösen wir sie
solidarisch lösen wir sie so dass wir
die schwächsten entlasten und die die
viel geld belasten oder tun wir das
nicht und da sag noch mal dass eine so
große abhängigkeit von russischen gas da
ist ist eine folge politischer
entscheidung falscher politischer
entscheidung nicht kritisieren wieder
ganz gesund die demonstration richte
sich aber darum jetzt so einer
solidarischen verteilung der
krisenlasten zum sommer sprachen
doch was dazu bin ich sage herr putin
als gas abgedreht haben müssen sich dazu
bekennen dass das der fall ist und
niemand anders und dann überlegen sie
noch was was glauben sie wären sie am
montag dann auch treffen wollen sie die
auch noch treffen braucht der straße für
die auf die sie meinen
die ankündigen was also ich appelliere
an die zusammen über gesellschaft und
das die demokratischen partei
einem schönen frau wissler die sie
vielleicht noch ein bisschen weniger
mögen klaus ernst schlägt ausgerechnet
einer ihrer parteifreunde vor dass wir
doch einfach nord stream zwei die
leitung wieder aufmachen können wir ob
wir jetzt aus nord stream 1 oder aus
nord zum 2 das gas brauchen was uns
fehlt oder holen sei doch eigentlich
egal was halten sie von diesem vorschlag
mehr gerechtigkeit indem wir nord stream
zwei aufmachen das ist nicht die
position der partei und das ist auch
nicht meine position im übrigen
erschließt sich mir das auch einfach
logisch nicht weil wir haben im moment
keine probleme der gas infrastruktur
sondern mit der gasmenge und wenn putin
oder russland weniger gas liefert dann
ist das in zweifall egal ob das durch
eine zwei oder drei pipelines geschieht
also von daher ist mir überhaupt nicht
klar wie dieses problem also wie
nordrhein zwei die öffnung von zwei das
problem lösen sollte von daher haben wir
da eine ganz klare position als partei
so nouripour ist dran mit der
beantwortung der frage wie diese
entlastungen jetzt eigentlich
organisiert werden können indem nächsten
paket henry poole der bundeskanzler
hatte das angekündigt er hat auch gesagt
dass es unbedingt um mehr gerechtigkeit
gehen muss wie sehr darum gestritten
wird haben wir im kleinen in bezug auf
diese das umlage schon diskutiert die
einen wünschen sich eine über gewinn
steuer die anderen wünschen sich dass
die schuldenbremse aufgelöst wird der
dritte wünscht sich was anderes ist es
bei der gas umlage jetzt im kleinen so
wie sie am ende weiter streiten werden
in dieser regierung oder glauben sie
sich dass sie sich verständigen werden
auf etwas was die menschen wirklich
entlastet und dieses hier sind
entlastungen da sind wieder belastungen
diese neue entlastungen wieder
belastungen einfach weitergeht also die
entlastung sind ja die antwort auf die
belastungen die wir nicht nicht aber sie
lösen die lauer um einen quasi sie
hätten dass das für die hoffen weil ich
ganz kurz zu den vorherigen was sagen
eine total total dankbar dass frau vista
sich ab von diesem begriff montags sich
der montagsdemonstration nicht an eignet
weil er ging es um freiheit und hier
geht es um preise und ich bin aber nicht
einverstanden damit dass die
bundesregierung verantwortlich sei für
den zusammenhalt in der regierung in der
in der gesellschaft das sind wir alle
zusammen die antwort auf die frage ist
wir werden sehr bald zusammenkommen als
regierung und miteinander diskutieren
all die vorschläge energie pauschale
noch mal weitergehen auch natürlich für
rentnerinnen und rentner hat die frage
von kindergelderhöhungen die frage
einführung kinder grundsicherung damit
wir kinderarmut in diesem jahr nicht
alles aufzählen henry vor glauben sie
und sie sich verständigen
selbstverständlich das ist der job und
das wissen auch alle in der
bundesregierung wir haben auch die
letzten zwei mal ins hinbekommen paket
auf dem weg zu bringen die eine familie
mit zwei kindern in diesem jahr im
schnitt ungefähr 900 euro netto
entlasten und wir wissen dass das nicht
reicht und es gibt halt mal schrille
zwischentöne hier und da das stimmt aber
wir haben bisher immer geliefert es zwar
nur weitermachen dazu hören wir
einsparen gleich vorher hören wir jemand
anders hier bemühen und sie mal um einen
perspektivwechsel exakt an dieser stelle
eckart von hirschhausen ist auch aus
bonn zugeschaltet in dieser sendung er
ist sehr herzlich begrüße engagiert sich
für science for future und hat auch
einen aufruf gegen den import von
russischem gas mit unterschrieben und da
sind wir genau bei dem was wir gerade
diskutiert haben eckart von hirschhausen
müssen sie sich auch jeden tag
entscheiden ob man jetzt weiter für die
ukraine kämpft und die sanktionen durch
hält oder ob wir klimaschutz betreiben
und das klima schützen oder ist es in
ihrem kopf gar keinen
hopp oder top
ja ich habe ja von anfang an die
diskussion mit verfolgen können und sind
alles wichtige themen mit dem wir uns
hier beschäftigen aber ein paar
wahrheiten drohen auch heute wieder viel
zu kurz zu kommen wir reden die ganze
zeit über gas so als wäre das eine
supersache
ganz wichtig ist mir zu sagen das ist
eine extrem dreckige verharrte die
energie zu erzeugen bei der gewinnung
von erdgas wird extrem viel methan frei
mit herrn ist 30 mal klimaschädlicher
als co2
das heißt wir sollten dringend darüber
reden heimat wie haben die bürger dieses
landes im winter eine warme gute aber im
moment auch die nachrichten der letzten
wochen waren davon bestimmt haben wir
haben völlig anderes problem dass es
viel zu heiß ist und ich vermisse den
zusammenhang zwischen diesen themen
alles was wir jetzt an investitionen in
fossile infrastruktur geben wird uns
teuer zu stehen kommen und zwar einen
preis der im moment noch gar nicht
eingepreist das ist der preis für die
nächsten generationen
wir haben heute in nrw wieder schule wir
haben 40 grad in klassenzimmern und was
werden diese kinder uns allen in 30
jahren weniger verzeihen temporär
gestiegene energiepreise oder für immer
gestiegene meeresspiegel böden auf denen
nichts mehr wächst und wälder die
abgebrannt sind und hier jetzt sehen
natürlich auch in ihrem hintergrund
bilder aus bonn von dem schönen rhein
der leider mit immer weniger wasser
gefüllt ist ja ich da ich darf einmal
kurz ich habe hierfür wissen vor 8 erde
gedreht und sie wollte nicht fliegen
sinnvollerweise zu ihnen deswegen ist es
sich hier aber dieses foto habe hier
gemacht im rhein das ist eine der
größten europäischen flüsse und im
moment sitzt man dann mitten im
flussbett und könnte heulen über diese
hunger steine die plötzlich sichtbar
werden über ein rinnsal was eben und da
bin ich traurig auch dass alle die sich
so auf ihre wirtschaftskompetenz berufen
nicht anerkennen dass wirtschaft
infrastruktur braucht wir brauchen
asphalt der nicht schmidt wir brauchen
flüsse die befahrbar sind und all das
ist viel viel verletzlicher als wir uns
das vorgestellt haben als arzt denke ich
natürlich auch an die krankenhäuser die
nicht gekühlt sind an die schulen die
nicht gekürzt und an die altenheime an
deutschland als ein rekordhalter bei den
hitze toten all das habe ich im
hinterkopf und deswegen kommt mir die
diskussion um mehrwertsteuer hier ein
bisschen da ein bisschen absurd wenn wir
das große bild nicht auch einmal mit
diskutieren das tun der an der stelle
und fragen auch sie natürlich was
glauben sie wie haben wir uns diese
abhängigkeit überhaupt eingebrockt die
uns jetzt in eine situation bringen wo
wir auf der einen seite eine
versorgungssicherheit eine
funktionierende industrie andererseits
sanktionen in diesem krieg so viele
krisen zu bewältigen haben woher kam
diese abhängigkeit die abhängigkeit ist
klar seit 50 jahren ist die diagnose
klar er muss aber bei der therapie
verzettelt erneuerbare energien hätten
in den letzten jahrzehnten viel viel
schneller vorangebracht werden können
und es gibt auch parteien und es gibt
auch eine fossile
lobby in diesem land die das massiv
verändert hat und darüber müssen wir
auch sprechen
gesundheitsvorteile der erneuerbaren was
ist der größte killer verschmutzung alle
verbrennungsvorgänge von fossiler
energie geht immer mit luftverschmutzung
einher kohlekraftwerke geben sieben
tonnen quecksilber
in die luft warum reden wir darüber
nicht dass wir ein stau haben von den
genehmigungen von windanlagen und wir
kriegen schneller ein
customer nämlich als endlich die
windenergie auf die straße zu bringen
von der mir lange geredet haben also
nach vorne raus müssen wir uns völlig
ehrlich machen dass das nicht eine krise
ist die vorbei geht sondern die
klimakrise ist da sie ist echt süß
menschen gemacht und sie wird jedes jahr
schlimmer die kosten auch für die
wirtschaft werden jedes jahr höher je
länger wir so wenig tun wie jetzt so und
jetzt kommen diese aufrufe zum sparen
natürlich bei den menschen an weil sie
not haben und weil sie vielleicht auch
ohnehin überzeugt etwas für den
klimaschutz tun wollen aber die preise
weiter steigen in einer solchen
situation nochmal die frage wie
motiviert man menschen diesen
klimaschutz nicht nur nicht zu vergessen
sondern ihnen eigentlich dann auch als
eine zentrale aufgabe zu sehen
meine stiftung gesunde erde gesunde
menschen versucht genau an dieser stelle
anzusehen da wünsche ich mir auch dass
wir uns viel mehr darüber unterhalten
welche feld wir eigentlich hinwollen
statt nur darüber zu reden was wir jetzt
alles für belastungen haben die größte
belastung ist und bleibt die klimakrise
sie macht das leben auf diesem planeten
für uns menschen unmöglich dass der
höchste preis den wir zahlen und all das
ist nicht mit eingepreist im moment wenn
wir an der mehrwertsteuer etwas ändern
menschen brauchen nicht nur wärme sie
brauchen auch was zu essen warum haben
wir immer noch mehrwertsteuer auf
gesundem essen wie obst und gemüse und
warum sucht dazu gehen wir immer noch
fleisch warum in einer weltweiten krise
und einer weltweiten hungerkrise
schieben wir immer noch 70 prozent des
getreides in tiere seien das sind solche
absurditäten die uns alle überfordern
mich auch und deswegen weiß ich auch
dass es das alles nicht lustig ist und
vielleicht manche haben gehofft werden
die chancen kommt wird es ein bisschen
lustig nee wir sind wirklich in einer
extrem bedrohlichen situation da muss
ich erst sagen erst mal die klare
diagnose herr kircher 14,4 also ich bin
das mittelpunkt der schau so sehr
dankbar weil das ist eigentlich unser
haupt hebel und das müssen einfach
erkennen deshalb den chancen zu tun
dieser vielen krisen die wir jetzt haben
wir haben uns jetzt heute haben
natürlich nur über die kleinen pflaster
unterhalten die notfallmaßnahmen was
comedy und datum wirklich keinen
einzigen wir richtig beschleunigen in
der transformation um die vielen wänden
die energiewende die klimawende
die dekarbonisierung die mobilitäts
wende zu schaffen und da und habe gesagt
herr von hirschhausen da fehlt die
infrastruktur damit wir das können dann
wird die digitale netz dafür die letzte
überhaupt so und da müssen wir natürlich
investieren dann bin ich wieder am
anfang wenn die industrie nicht das geld
hat zu investieren werden wir langsamer
sagen ich bin der bundesregierung
einfach an dem
besitz der buschmann dankbar dass er
heute richtung kabinetts und richtung
parlament ein entwurf gemacht hat und
aber ich hab's angekündigt wie wir
beschleunigen planungs und genau so
haben so beschleunigt werden wir haben
noch weniger als sieben halbjahre zeit
bis 2030